salut dans la première vidéo on a un
produit des intuitions qui définissent
l'expérience naït que l'on fait de
l'existence
on a évoqué quelques problèmes liés aux
croyances notamment vis-à-vis de la
question du grès et des attentes
maintenant il faut voir ça plus en
détails donc partant de la vivre
implique de se faire une idée de ce
qu'est le monde via un ensemble de
choses que l'on tient pour vrai à propos
de la réalité dans son ensemble à
partiront donc comme on disait
personne ne vit sans se faire une idée
de ce qu'est le monde déjà il faut
s'arrêter un instant parce que j'ai
employé des mots très relou en
philosophie le mot réalité et le verbe
être je laisse être de côté pour le
moment c'est vraiment vraiment heureux
la conception naïve de la réalité comme
on l'a dit renvoie à ce qui m'entoure ce
qui m'entoure semble exister
indépendamment de moins c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi le monde
ce qui me fait face ceux qui résistent à
ma volonté par indépendant de moi
j'entends en fait indépendant de ma
seule volonté
je ne peux pas simplement décidé que la
réalité soit autrement il faut que je me
heurte à elle pour la transformer cette
impression est problématique parce
qu'elle n'est pas vraisemblable et qui
semble pourtant impossible sondés faire
dans notre expérience du quotidien jeudi
qu'elle n'est pas vraisemblable parce
que en réalité il n'y a pas de face à
face entre un sujet et un objet l'état
des connaissances disponibles nous
encouragerait plutôt à dire qu'il ya de
la matière qui forment un cerveau et que
ce cerveau produit une expérience
consciente puisque l'expérience
consciente et généré par le cerveau
lui-même étant de la matière elle est le
monde
elle est littéralement un produit parmi
tant d'autres de ce qu'on appelle la
réalité
l'expérience consciente mais qu en
apparence séparé de la réalité vous
refusez cette idée il faudrait défendre
un gaullisme naïf c'est à dire l'idée
qu'il y aurait la réalité spirituelle
d'à côté et le monde matériel de l'autre
que notre esprit serait indépendant de
notre corps et qu'il serait le pur
témoin de la réalité bon en ce sens
puisque nous avons tous un cerveau mais
que nous n'avons pas tous le même
cerveau il ya des points communs à notre
expérience consciente et des points de
divergence
c'est important parce que cela veut dire
que tout ce qui est perçu est réel ce
qui n'implique évidemment pas que toutes
les perceptions se valent on n'a pas
encore abordé la question des valeurs
mais toute expérience consciente est un
morceau du monde et si nous voulons
composer avec la réalité
il faut composer avec les différences de
perception pour autant l'impression
dualiste est constitutif de notre
expérience de l'existence combien parmi
ceux qui savent que l'esprit est un
produit du
or agit effectivement à rebours de cette
intuition dualisme quand on observe les
débats combien prennent en compte par
exemple que le libre arbitre aussi forte
soit l'impression que nous avons dans
jouir est une hypothèse de moins en
moins crédible que ce face à face est
une illusion en quelque sorte faut-il
essayer d'intégrer cette image
scientifique à notre existence
faut-il tenter d'en faire un levier pour
modifier notre rapport instinctif à la
vie et sinon pourquoi j'insiste là
dessus parce que trop souvent les vidéos
sur la rationalité ne présente qu'un
versant de la croyance la croyance
consciente
je crois que hic c'est vrai on met de
côté ce qu'on pourrait appeler
d'assimilation ou l'incorporation le
fait d'intégrer une croyance à son
expérience donc voir spontanément la
réalité différemment
c'est une forme tout autre de rapport à
la croyance sûrement la plus accomplie
et être rationnel ce n'est pas être
constamment en système 2 pour reprendre
l'expression de cannes et man c'est à
dire dans la commission lente analytique
fatigante
ce n'est pas éteindre tous rapports
intuitif au monde devenir plus rationnel
c'est nourrir de meilleur intuition donc
comment choisis ton le savoir analytique
à transformer en intuition pourquoi
certains défenseurs de la pensée
sceptiques à tactile leurs adversaires
comme si nous étions des consciences
libres et d incarner cela procède-t-il
d'une décision rationnelle
ce n'est pas clair disons ceci pour le
moment
l'expérience consciente dépend
entièrement de conditions matérielles au
sens où elle dépend un du corps à la
fois le cerveau et ma constitution
organique
si mon estomac et douloureux je le sens
tout bêtement et 2 de la réalité au sens
large c'est-à-dire aussi bien comme
stimulation sensorielle puisque mon
expérience dépend du climat de l'aluminé
et c'est que comme stimulation affective
mon expérience dépend des causes de
joies et les tristesses qui se trouvent
autour de moi ce n'est pas pareil de
vivre un temps de guerre ou en temps de
prospérité pacifique que comme
stimulation intellectuelle puisque mon
expérience dépend du savoir à
disposition savoir qui lui même est
tributaire évidemment de la réalité
matérielle prise au sens large les
outils techniques et les outils de
diffusion de transmission etc
nous éprouvons la vie comme si notre
expérience consciente et est
relativement indépendante de toutes ces
conditions
jeudi relativement indépendante parce
qu'on a l'intuition que notre expérience
sensorielle dépend de la réalité
matérielle mais nous avons aussi
l'intuition que nos sentiments et nos
idées existent selon une logique propre
exemple si j'échoue je comprends que
c'est une affaire de température en
revanche si je suis triste et que je me
demande pourquoi je ne cherche pas
spontanément la cause dans mon corps je
cherche à produire une interprétation
psychologique je ressens la tristesse
comme une chose qui tient à des
représentations à des idées parfois il
est impossible de démêler l'idée de son
incarnation dans le corps par exemple si
je viens deuil une rupture là il est
compréhensible qu'on ne cherche pas à
réduire ça à des mécanismes biologiques
mais très souvent notre humeur change
d'elle même on subit alors les
représentations associées à ce
changement
sans se souvenir que si c'est bien notre
corps qui produit nos humeurs alors
peut-être que ces représentations ne
tienne à rien d'autre qu'un mouvement
physiologique
par exemple on a découvert que des juges
était plus clément après avoir déjeuné
évidemment il ne se rendait pas compte
c'est quand même pas anodin
et puis aussi on a l'intuition d'être
lucide l'intuition qu'on est capable de
faire la part des choses
on pense qu'il ya d'un côté la réalité à
laquelle on a accès par la perception et
de l'autre ce qu'on pense et ressent
notre perception du monde ne serait en
aucun cas influencer par notre humeur où
nos préférences donc les valeurs
auxquelles on adhère
on ne pense pas toute la journée que la
manière était qu'elle le monde nous
apparaît dépend de ce que nous sommes
cet oubli n'est pas anodin du tout on
entretient constamment on a donc des
croyances qui à nos yeux des cribles la
réalité en tant que monde qui nous
transcende aussi bien je crois qu'il ya
une pomme devant moi je crois que le
soleil se lèvera demain je crois que
j'ai rêvé jean claude van damme cette
nuit je crois que je suis amoureux de
telle personne mais également des
croyances relatives à des choses plus
complexes sur le fonctionnement du monde
on peut croire à la méritocratie penser
que l'être humain est wade au libre
arbitre comme on disait on peut se faire
une idée de la répartition des richesses
dans le monde voire même se faire une
conception de ce qu'est la justice de ce
que devrait être le fonctionnement la
zone euro etc
on peut essayer de classe et nos
croyances en fonction de différents
critères
par exemple selon qu'elles sont plutôt
simples ou plutôt complexe et selon
qu'elle se rapporte à moi même ou non
comme je crois que j'ai besoin de dormir
où je crois que ma colère était en fait
l'expression d'une tristesse et pour le
monde
je crois que spinoza est l'auteur de
l'éthique où je croit en l'existence du
boson de higgs noter qu'il ya des
expressions un peu ambigu
3 on semble décrire le monde mais en
fait on parle de ce qu'on ressent il ya
des croyants sur le monde d'un autre
ordre comme c'est lui qui est
responsable de leur dispute ou cette
expérience a changé sa vie où il est
tombé amoureux d'elle parce qu'il admire
son intelligence ici on a affaire à des
interprétations et des spéculations
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que même si
ces énoncés très tendre d'écrire quelque
chose qui serait la réalité on a
généralement conscience au moment où les
formules qu'on ne pourra jamais vraiment
vérifier s'ils sont juste on projette
des états mentaux chez l'autre
remarquons que ce n'est pas rien tout de
même comme attitude de s'autoriser à
penser qu'autrui a fait ceci parce
qu'ils pensaient cela mais il semble
qu'on puisse pas s'en empêcher il y a
donc sept autres catégories de croyance
encore plus complexe les phrases
relatives à ce qui est bon ou mauvais et
donc à ce qu'il faut ne faut pas faire
il ne devrait pas faire des études de
philosophie on trouve pas de métier
après ça c'est au gouvernement de
prendre des mesures écologiques ferme
il devrait arrêter de manger de la
viande ça engage ce qu'on appelle les
tic ce n'est pas anodin déclaré que
telle chose et poney telles choses
mauvaises
si c'est logique de se dire qu'il faut
prendre le temps d'interroger des
énoncés relatifs à la morale il ne faut
pas non plus perdre un temps inutile à
questionner toutes nos attentions
par exemple torturé un enfant ça me
semble effectivement immoral peut-être
que je pourrai passer du temps à me
demander ce qui fonde cette intuition
mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
super intéressant de remettre ça en
cause
il est souvent très difficile de douter
nos intuitions morale la torture
l'esclavagé la cruauté
on n'en doute pas on le sent en plus
profond de nous on a envie de dire je le
sais parce que je le sens dans mes
tripes mais ça ne peut pas suffire à
justifier une croyance moral de dire ça
tous les matchs du monde ressemblent
dans leur trip la supériorité masculine
tous les pro-life ressentent dans leurs
prix l'horreur moral de l'avortement
tous les islamophobes ressemblent dans
leur trip le danger de l'islam comment
distinguer les cas qu'ils méritent
interrogés des autres peut-être tout
simplement quand des gens disent le
contraire
et quand c'est le cas on peut faire
appel à la raison pour établir des
critères et essayer de résoudre la
question
je ne dis pas que c'est facile mais
c'est théoriquement possible
l'investigation rationnelle suppose de
mettre en lumière les liens entre les
sentiments et les croyances morale afin
d'espérer un consensus ou à minima une
meilleure compréhension mutuelle
si être rationnel supposé de ne jamais
s'occuper de morale alors je ne serais
pas présenté
sans le point de vue des uns et les
autres est fondée sur des sentiments et
des raisons il faut sans doute éclairé
comment ces énoncés s'articule pour
réussir à faire la différence entre un
énoncé morale crédible et un énoncé le
moral douteux ce qui ne veut pas dire
que c'est la présence de sentiments qui
rend un énoncé douteux vouloir me sentir
en sécurité
c'est un sentiment qui font d'un droit
ça n'a pas la même valeur morale que le
sentiment qui donne envie de dominer
autrui par exemple souvent les
justifications apportées par les uns et
par les autres sont justement ça tombe
bien des descriptions de la réalité
historiquement le racisme à commencer
par sa montée des justifications
biologique par exemple aujourd'hui ce
serait plutôt des justifications
culturel les premières étaient plus
faciles à des bunkers que les seconds
idéalement quand on peut démontrer que
le fondement factuel et erronée la
croyance morales devrait être abandonné
le problème c'est que les propositions
orales ne sont pas que des
juxtapositions de croyance factuel ce
sont aussi des désirs des projections
autour de ce que pourrait devenir la
société
elle participe d'une idéologie ce sont
deux dimensions à l'interroger croire
que l'on est dépourvue de toute
idéologie simplement parce que l'on
adhère pas consciemment à une idéologie
et terriblement naïf et c'est dangereux
c'est prendre le risque de perpétuer une
idéologie sans en rendre compte
peut-être qu'on peut faire cette
hypothèse plus une croyance morale
suppose pour être justifiée
d'explication complexe plus il semble
judicieux de le traiter avec
circonspection
si j'ai l'intuition forte que
l'avortement c'est mal mais que pour le
prouver il faut en passer par des
considérations très complexe autour du
statut du foetus de ce qui définit une
vie humaine
peut-être que je devrais tempéré mon
intuition parce que si je suis mon
intuition sans réfléchir je peut militer
contre l'avortement et mon militantisme
pourrait avoir un impact concret sur la
vie de certaines personnes
donc avant d'agir en vertu d'une
position morale il convient de se
demander à quel point on a confiance en
elle
si je suis incapable détaillé ma
position si je n'ai pour la justifier
que mon sentiment
alors peut-être est-ce le devoir en
vertu de la règle d'or de contraindre
des réflexes moreau induits par cette
croyance vous connaissez sans doute le
principe diététique une information
extraordinaire demande des preuves
extraordinaires
mais on entend surtout pour des croyants
surprenante du type la terre est plate
ce serait intéressant de l'appliquer à
ces affirmations du quotidien
d'apparence moins spectaculaire mais qui
sont font très présentes tueuse comme la
spéculation sur les intentions d'une
personne ou sur la moralité d'une
décision puisque ce sont là des choses
finalement très complexe et incertaine
on pourrait donc défendre l'idée que
toute interprétation aux spéculations
demande à être étayé et que toute
proposition relative à ce que l'on doit
ou ne doit pas faire cuire à minima une
explicitation aussi fine que possible de
ce qui fonde la perspective morale qui
se cache derrière la croyance les
croyances relatives à la psychologie
d'autrui et à la morale sont parmi les
choses les plus importantes de notre
existence
c'est ce qui va définir notre
comportement en général il apparaît donc
indispensable de se demander quels sont
les croyances derrière mes croyances
qu'est ce qui nous pousse à croire qu'il
faut agir ainsi bon c'est tout pour
cette fois mais je vous encourage encore
à aller voir la suite